have it.
In the morning,
remember
day
next.
for
is the
priority
thing here
behavior.
Life
and reflect.
It's a
we
have
or not.
However,
consideration.
We'll have
money
of
what we have coming in our income and
our outgoing sp expenditures
expenditures.
We know that that has to be balanced and
you have to be conscious of it. What
about if you just got your paycheck and
just bought whatever came to your mind
on a whim. No planning. No planning. You
don't look at it. You don't refount or
your balance. You just keep swiping your
card or spending the money until you get
an until you get declined.
What's going to happen to your finances?
you are going to absolutely run yourself
into the ground. Correct? You have to
have a careful balance. And this is what
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
teaches us here with respect to our
deeds. Now, if you were to imagine that,
let's say you designed for yourself a
method that every time you spent a
dollar
on something that you want or something
that you'd you have to save $2 in
its place.
Every time you spend a dollar, you have
to spend two you have to put away $2 in
its place. Is it possible for you to
even if you don't keep track? You don't
keep track. You just follow that one
rule. That's the rule. You don't break
the rule. The rule is every time I spend
a dollar, I save two. I put away two.
Will you ever run out of money? It's
impossible. It is physically impossible.
You're not keeping count. You're just
following that one rule. It is then
physically impossible to run out of
money. This narration
is that same rule with our deeds. Listen
closely. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says,
"Observe the obedience of Allah wherever
you are, anywhere you are.
and always follow up a sin with a good
deed and it will erase it
and deal with people in the best of
ways. That's the formula. We know that
the prophet sallallah that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
He promises us that whoever does one
good deed,
it will be rewarded to him at least
tenfold. At least. And whoever does a
bad deed, it will only be counted as
one.
Therefore, if I back to our analogy, if
I for every dollar I spend on something
I want,
I save $10 in its place, will I ever go
broke? I won't ever go broke. As a
matter of fact, I will get actively
wealthy by doing this. Correct? Now, I
don't want you to look at sins as
spending money.
This happens.
It happens that people look at it like,
you know, they look at food. You know,
I'm on a diet, but then I have a cheat
day, right? I dabble in this. I can
afford this. You cannot afford a single
sin.
Not one.
You cannot afford a single sin. Why?
Because
once you have that sin,
you have definitely committed to
disobedience
and you are not certain what Allah will
do with that sin.
We remember the narration
of the man
who the the man with the loaf of bread.
I told this story a few times here
many months ago.
However, that story really captures the
essence of
our sin and our good deeds. We know the
story of the prostitute who gave the dog
a drink of water. Right? We also know
the story of the woman who went to the
hellfire because of a cat. Correct?
This was a single sin. The other was a
single good deed. However, that one sin
led to what? Led to damnation.
Because if you were to imagine with me
here
that I had two
two sides of a scale
and every time I placed a grain of sand
on one side of this scale and a grain of
sand on the other, eventually if I'm not
exactly equal with that, at least equal
with that, one side will eventually one
day what be outweighed by the other. And
what made it outweigh? What was the
grain or the straw that broke the
camel's back? It was one grain of sand.
Right now, you and I, we don't know what
our balance is with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. We have promises that were made
to us in the Quran. We have an
approximation. However, when we do a
good deed, we don't know if Allah has
accepted it. He is the king. He accepts
what he chooses. When we do a bad deed,
we know that we have offended. We don't
know if Allah will forgive it. He is the
king. He he forgives whom he chooses
and he brings to account whom he
chooses. Therefore, we do not we have to
look at our balance and only focus on
our good deeds in the sense that
whenever I do a bad deed, I will at
least do one good deed and I will take
every single good deed seriously. I will
not allow a single good deed to escape
my clutches. Why? Because I need every
single one
because one day you one day me, myself,
every human being. One day you're going
to do something. It may have been a good
deed or it may be a bad deed. And it
will be that single grain of sand that
tips your scales.
It will be that single grain of sand
that tips your scales. Who knows? We may
have already done it in our lives. Maybe
it's already passed. The prophet
sallall.aii
said, "A man will say
something, will make a statement of the
pleasure of Allah, not thinking twice
about it, and
Allah will write for him his pleasure
until the day of judgment because of
that one statement."
And conversely, a man may open his mouth
and make a statement, not thinking twice
about it, and Allah will write him in
his displeasure, in his anger until the
day that he meets him. And another
wording, and he may fall because of that
one single statement into the fire of
hell for 70 years. It doesn't mean that
when you do a good deed, it's not
counted or when you do a bad deed, it's
not counted. No. What's meant here is
that good deeds and bad deeds, they are
largely judged by intentions.
And the intensity of our good deed and
the intensity of our bad deed is taken
into account. And so we have to be very
careful with every single grain of sand
we allow to be placed on that scale.
Anytime a sin comes up, we fight as hard
as we can to not allow that grain of
sand to be placed on that side of the
scale. And every time the opportunity
for a good deed comes up, we fight as
hard as we can to perform that good deed
and get that grain of sand onto that
side of the scale. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam tells us
the default is obedience.
Observe the tawa of Allah. Fear Allah.
Obey Allah wherever you are, private or
public, masid or marketplace.
He says,
"And follow up every sin with a good
deed and it will erase it immediately."
Don't wait till tomorrow because you'll
lose count. It's a whole lifetime you
have ahead of you. But make that your
constant. I stay away from sin. But sin
will inevitably happen. Every one of us
disobys.
But when it does happen, you're
immediately conscious of it and
immediately start looking for a good
deed to do in its place. And that is the
first thing that a shaitan will try to
get you to not do. When you commit this
the sin
and then you start looking to do a good
deed even if it's just two even if it's
giving a dollar in charity even if it is
any good deed that you know to be good
a shan will come and say you just sinned
and now a hypocrite you're coming
to make it seem and he'll start to
whisper right the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells you that if you
commit a sin immediately Simply start
looking for the first good deed you can
do that is
that is that is complements that
sin meaning that it is similar to that
sin. If it is a a a bad thing in this
particular field you want to do a good
deal a good thing in that particular
field. And this will this will start
that struggle in your heart between good
and evil.
And good will always what? Always.
Isn't that the promise of the Quran?
that that the end will always be for
and the always, always,
no matter what happens in the middle, no
matter what battles are lost on the way.
The war between good and evil, good will
always prevail.
Subhanahu
[Silence]
Was Muhammad
Goodness.